やっと届きましたよ
[音楽]
ブーブーかーっ
えっなんかやっぱ大変だろうと思うんで
医者がまったけどこなくてもうヤバイと思って
あのん
会社に聞いたら
なんかメール返ってきて全然発送日出遅れてませんした
others みたいな面で帰ってきたらもう
めっちゃ行ったんですよ嫌ですよ
10じざけんじゃねーけど絶対つい電気で通わせるために本当にん
まずみんなか電気でこんな方がいいですよ
[音楽]
その金造会は最高で続けていきますを開きましたけど
どえねーっドバイバールっていう阿部らはを切っ
me
おおお
すごい
[音楽]
そ白かったですよ
どうですかいい
さあタッチパネルって書いてる止めてんさーな的だありがとう展示
電気西コースねやっぱ保険た分だけ良いものを届けてくれるっていうさすが電気ぜひ皆
生きるかはね本当に
もうアレじゃないですかで作ったらカメラっぽいんですけど本当にあのだ室が
えぐいんですよね
すごい
今作っているカフェなう
こっちに切り替えますねー
以上ですがめっちゃ綺麗でさぁ
[音楽]
なんか自分でみないとわかんないんですけど
トレード本当にやっと届いたんですよと言う
動画でした
ぜひ皆さん
今後動画はこのがすべくから
なってるよじゃあねっ
ni
いやーすごいですねー
実は映画みたい